hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
book three of lucretius's poem the
nature of things or the nature of the
universe depending on how you want to
translate it
is discussing the human mind what it is
that is distinctive to us and what it is
that we also share with the other
animate the other animal things
and there's two terms that are going to
be used not synonymously
but
in conjunction with each other quite a
bit both of them have the same
stem there's anamus and then there's
anama and we typically translate animus
as mind or we can also translate it as
intellect
then there's anama which sometimes gets
translated as soul but for the purposes
of discussion here we're going to follow
the typical translation as
spirit and
these according to lucretius are
interconnected with each other and with
the
human body so he's very keen to spell
out for us what kind of things these
actually are and he begins by talking
about the mind he says first i maintain
that the mind which we often call the
intellect interestingly the word that
we're translating there is intellect is
men's which is closer to
mind in english
this is our our intellectual capacity
our powers he calls it the seat of the
guidance and control of life so the
thing that's running the show so to
speak and then he says this is a part
of the human being
it's not the entirety of the human being
as some people would say
it's not something foreign to the human
being it is a part he says no less than
hand or foot or eyes are parts of a
whole
living creature
and he goes on a little bit further
down down the line and talks more about
this
dominant force that the the intellect or
the mind
is he tells us
he calls it the head and the dominant
force in the whole body
being that guiding principle which we
term the mind or intellect the mind or
intellect if it's doing its job right
we'll actually be running the show
there's probably a lot of thought
processes as well going on below the
level of our consciousness that are
playing an important role as well and he
tells us that it is lodged within
the chest now this is kind of an
interesting thing to point out because
you know
we late moderns tend to associate the
mind primarily with the brain which we
know is located up here in our head
and you know you might say well why
would it be located in the breast well
that was a common place for the ancient
greeks to think of the
mind those capacities being located in
some commentators point out that the
argument here that he's providing
doesn't necessarily get us the entirety
of the mind or intellect being located
in the chest it could also be diffused
through the body but certainly that's
where the emotions
are taking place and he says here is the
place where fear and alarm pulsate here
is felt the caressing touch of joy
here then is the seat of intellect and
mind right so the the intellect or mind
is
in a particular
area i mean it's kind of able to move
around a bit as we can see but
that's that's that's quite important
and so um we're going to see that
there's also another thing that he
brings up the anima he says you must
understand there's also a vital spirit
in our limbs and the body does not
derive its sentience from any harmony
uh he's concerned to like combat that
error which we'll talk about elsewhere
and then he tells us
that the
mind and the spirit are interconnected
konyenkta right
sometimes he'll actually use
metaphors with the mind spirit and body
of um a marriage right and so they are
they're intertwined is another way or
entangled you could say with each other
and the
the anama
unlike the
the intellect of the mind
is actually spread throughout the
entirety of the body but the parts where
it's you know bringing itself into
contact with the intellect it's going to
be interconnected interfused
with it and as he says they form a
single some translations say substance
nature is a little bit closer to the
original latin text you know unum
right so a single
thing
throughout all of our body
and you know he goes on talking about
this
these are interconnected with the body
and he says that you know when we look
at a person where our head or our eye
suffers from an attack a pain
our whole body does not share and it's
aching just so the mind sometimes
suffers by itself or jumps for joy when
the rest of the spirit is not stirred by
any impulse
but when the mind is upset by some more
overwhelming fear we see the spirit in
every limb upset in sympathy sweat and
poller the whiteness right break out
over the body speech grows inarticulate
the voice fails the eyes grow dim the
ears buzz the limbs totter
often we see men actually drop down
because the terror that has gripped
their minds and i'm pointing at my head
but it really should be pointing at the
chest so he says hence you may readily
infer a connection between the mind and
the spirit which when shaken by the
impact of the mind immediately jostles
and propels the body now
how could this in fact be the case
lucretius wants to say
that shows us
that the
the mind and the vital spirit that are
interconnected with each other
like the body
are
matter they are
material because otherwise there's no
way for them to interact with the body
itself and produce all of these
interesting effects that we see that
terror or fear
can in fact induce in a person so he
says the same reasoning proves that the
mind and spirit are both composed
of matter
why we see them propelling the limbs
rousing the body from sleep changing the
expression of the face guiding and
steering the whole person activities
that clearly involve touch as touch in
turn
involves matter so he says how can we
deny
this material nature then you see the
mind sharing in the body's experiences
and sympathizing with it and he's got a
kind of a gruesome example here when the
nerve-racking impact of a spear lays
bare bones and sinews even if it does
not penetrate to the seat of life there
ensues faintness and a falling towards
the ground and on the ground a turmoil
in the mind and an intermittent
faltering impulse to stand up again the
substance of the mind must therefore be
material
why because it suffers the impact of
material weapons so we could generalize
this
since we can for you know pleasure pain
or whatever else we want to say be
affected by
external things that bear upon our body
and we feel it not just in our body but
also in the vital spirit and the mind
the vital spirit of the mind must be
material so
if they are material from an epicurean
point of view remember lucretius belongs
to that school
there is going to be
a set of
atoms or particles
that both of these interconnected things
are
made of
so what what kind of matter is it he
says
mind and spirit
are a very fine texture right and
composed of exceptionally minut
particles and he says you can infer this
from the following facts nothing happens
as quickly as the mind represents and
sketches the happening to itself
therefore the mind sets into itself
emotion more swiftly than any of those
things whose substance is visible to our
eyes what is so mobile what's all
movable right
must consist of exceptionally
spherical
and
and minute atoms and so he brings up
some examples here like water flows
quite easily as opposed to honey
why is that well the water particles are
rounder and smaller than the honey
particles which are more uh you know
vicious right uh they they stick to each
other they don't roll as well right he's
got another great example of poppy seeds
if you've ever seen poppy seeds or
worked with it you got to be kind of
careful especially if there's a wind
because it'll just blow it away right
and they're tiny and they're very light
and so you got to be kind of uh you know
on your guard not to lose them well
that's what the intellect and the vital
spirit are like they're made of tiny
tiny
particles
and so they move around very simply
right he says the substance of the mind
is extraordinarily
mobile
and then he says here's a further
indication how flimsy is the texture of
the vital spirit in how small a space it
could be contained at the instant when a
person is mastered by the calm of death
and forsaken by mind and spirit
you cannot tell either by sight or by
weight that any part of the hole has
been filched away from the body the
the things that compose the mind and the
spirit are so tiny that we we can't even
see them whereas like the other stuff
that's you know our body itself
much larger particles and interestingly
you know there were experiments weighing
dead people shortly after they died to
like try to figure out you know was
there any
loss in material substance lucretius
would say no of course
you won't be able to notice any although
there will be like an infinitesimal
amount so this is what according to
lucretius our
minds and spirits actually
are they're material
things composites you could say of many
many many fine atoms that are spread
throughout and interconnected
interlocked you might even say
with our much
grosser and you know visible
and detectable bodies
you